usually my issue is I go to junk food I
go to go to trash like unhealthy food
and
it was such a revelation to me when I
realized that almost every time I go
I'm either super exhausted and there's a
lot of real clear literature that
suggests the more tired you are the more
hungry in the in the poorer the food
choices you make
but almost always there was some sort of
relational issue I was frustrated with
my wife my kids were driving me crazy I
was super annoyed with somebody at work
and I found myself mindlessly grabbing
junk food and I'm sure I could go down a
rabbit hole and figure out the
physiology I didn't really care what the
physiology was I just needed to know
that the trigger had something to do
with when my body felt exposed or lonely
or disconnected from folks